well yes
I did everything thankfully I had sex
with other girls
I did everything
all right here we go
we met in school we met in college um we
met in class and you really didn't like
me no I didn't like you a couple years
later we moved into like the same
apartment complex and the first day we
both moved there
we like met on the elevator again it was
like a reunion and then you offered to
bring my groceries upstairs and yeah we
spent a lot of time together like every
day I would say that she were my best
friend
yeah me too I would go through his phone
I was like see text messages or like
pictures to go now I would ask her about
it first line of any dysfunctional
relationship people go to each other's
phone not trust in each other and
sometimes he would lie and just say like
oh that's not true you know what you're
talking about and you said like oh I'll
stop Canadian one time I went to his
room and he had someone else's room and
he told me to leave and I went back to
my room I just cried like those
and I think I'm not like a little while
without talking to you and then he said
something like alright I'm not gonna do
it again there was kind of a point where
things weren't the same really just like
you would always go through my phone or
my computer yeah I didn't ask you if you
would go to that measure to - fine
whatever
why wouldn't you just leave I don't know
I think I was stupid
yeah I mean I'm him I don't know maybe I
wasn't counting
- this that would you know you hit the
hundreds like that's when you know you
did so much your sex life is a blur let
you forget names you know okay this is
when someone doesn't know their own
number cuz it's so high when they drive
by building one I don't like you I think
I [ __ ] somebody in there but they
don't remember who you're [ __ ] sick
of this beer should talk to my mother
right now [ __ ] what's up this oh she's
back yeah just my wish she was in the
relationship Oh
[Music]
it had more to do with me just not being
able to commit did this maybe just hold
it was it's not you with me [ __ ] yeah
this it was subtle it was very subtle
because I didn't at the time I really I
didn't want to I think just sometimes
were were just we're not on the same
page yeah I think that's true I guess
you should take him back right now if
you try oh yeah so what you're looking
at him annoys you eating up his words
and his [ __ ] she was there's nothing
that you could have done differently
that I think would have prevented it I
think that you did everything that you
needed to do to be a good girlfriend and
that's good though what right right no
okay here's what you need to understand
run if she's giving her what I call
primetime fuck-boy sweets all right you
say all the right things but you don't
need whatsoever I think he means it you
know what there's that like there's
nothing she would have been able to do
to afford it you don't care I don't
think what do you think is not right I'm
yeah I agree that what I am trying to
tell you is this she does not give a
[ __ ] he's just saying the right things
to say the right things I was lucky to
have gone on my cue this kind of big
vague illusion I know it because I've
done it and I seen it in other [ __ ]
and I know but when I see it literally
if anybody comes at me with some super
loop stuff out I need to find myself you
know I'm not too sure how I'm feeling
about life but I like spending time with
you I think you're wonderful
oh I read this it is okay this is one
big cut another big fine is that [ __ ]
haircut who has that haircut I can [ __ ]
Wow
I don't care what you say a lot about
you a lot point boy after you know that
suppose whether it's good that [ __ ]
little thing when they got that side cut
and they got a mushroom on top like gate
like they have a penis up here and a
penis down there you will say it's
unnecessary
that that Larry has a penis over you a
me what I realize I put myself in that
box
oh [ __ ] what I tell you I mean I told
you genius I gotta get yo hey I was a
hold on oh god no hold on
I was not convinced I was blind but now
I see okay hold up we gotta listen to
this cuz ya'll I'm telling you she
bought the wind up all his [ __ ]
Human Centipede right now because he
cheated
I forgave you
why
[Music]
because remember
so your best friend betrays you on a
regular basis likes your face tells you
some [ __ ] just so you feel mostly
better and you think you guys are
friends girl you got twisted definition
of friendship check yourself before you
wreck yourself thank you ah ha ha
I think we're like
and the first stage of moving on this is
his way of smoothly colors and [ __ ] me
ain't going backwards let me make that
clear we both kind of accepted for the
first time that it's really over no no
hold on hold on
he said weeks the flap I want you to
look at her Facebook of me what why I
talked apposite look at her feet I'm
telling you she ain't ready
I couldn't like today I couldn't see
like my life without you but I
it's like you hurt me a lot so I feel
like you abandoned me I apologize for
hurting you and I hope in the future you
become remain good friends no you know
when you have a relationship just a word
of advice well you haven't really ends
up like that inside to break off and
you'd be like yo can we be real friend
no it's just like having a dog and a dog
dying and saying can we still keep it
your dog is dead
move the [ __ ] home you don't want to
keep it because you know you remember
the good time
listen you need to bury that [ __ ] and
move the [ __ ] long way and make you feel
better and not hold on to some [ __ ] move
the [ __ ] on and I get a chance to see
you grow until the one that should be
coming she's eating it up she's smiley
she's smiling I cried because she misses
him this is he doesn't give a [ __ ] this
is blank place if I thought he probably
get some [ __ ] right after the show
using I already got Tiffany lined up how
you fellas hissing nice I got
[Music]
Courtney Leonard now live in different
states Excel top regularly
she's still tapping that ass that's what
that means you know I think they didn't
work out probably because she had that
stupid like front hair [ __ ] that he got
going on in the corner of her head Nikki
baby Aaron mom listen as much as I blame
the guy that girl is very responsible as
well all right he was very deceitful and
mostly vinegar but she also encouraged
it and she wasn't responsible enough
towards herself and she didn't respect
herself enough to get away from that
kind of influence and at some point
ladies you guys have to take
responsibility I can smell a [ __ ] board
coming from a mile away
I know it you can just hear it the way
they taught how a loose they are about
everything if someone's not going to
firmly say what they're thinking and not
be emotionally open open with you that's
a big big red flag okay
and this dude users watching that whole
interview how can you not see how
emotionally manipulative he was empathy
was not even safe none
you guys want me to put out a playbook
for a cry to watch out for fuzz boy yes
put out a playbook but I can definitely
do that
you know what though it's funny cuz my
girlfriend come up to me if you like yo
I met this girl we about to me and she's
gonna join us in the club I'm like okay
cool my my boy yo and I've let all boo
boo honey chicken cherry some honey bun
a bunch with a class of our military on
top no no no and here's what I was that
we're talking about but with this whole
video a lot of you ladies ain't [ __ ]
either so don't get it twisted he was
armed he mommy students and I let a lot
of them a lot of ladies ain't worth a
damn so okay I come y'all next book I'm
gonna get to the Dukes but I just wanna
tell you they're like I want I want to
see you hello unto you I am man
the woman doesn't know see all of this
set what you don't realize and the some
boy is doing all of that the all the
head gesture the army like your hand on
the phone it's like he's doing that you
just don't see this is a wage but
government is a little bit a bit of like
like see it's super slow down
well I just want to see oh okay
when was this I see it I see it
thanks for opening my eyes mammal woods
oh I got a lot more you guys want to see
that tutorial let me know in the
comments below that they want any other
you want to see about this is a fun gal
right to the club guys there's a girl
who is good for nothing I also can do
story for those I'm in the dating market
baby I know what I know
okay I got shot so let me know and
that's it
all right that's it for today's video if
you guys like that be sure to LIKE
subscribe Facebook YouTube well we don't
put everything on Facebook because
YouTube's our main [ __ ]
follow us on Instagram all that good
stuff we got a patreon page so if you
want donate a little bit money you give
us a little thumbs up then we do a
little time that we don't do I
definitely went the wrong direction job
well that's it so you know thanks Howard
a dollar makes me holler hello